en taiwán hablan de la mayor crisis en
40 años un conflicto recurrente con
chinas sobre todo en estas fechas cuando
se celebran las fiestas nacionales de
ambas partes carga política en la que
desde el viernes cerca de 150 aviones de
combate chinos cifra récord han cruzado
el conocido como adif la zona de
identificación aérea la primera adif fue
creada por eeuu en 1950 durante la
guerra de korea y desde entonces se han
extendido por todo el mundo se trata de
un espacio aéreo en el que la
identificación ubicación y control de
aeronaves se realiza en interés de la
seguridad nacional sin embargo no están
definidas en ningún tratado
internacional ni reguladas por ningún
organismo esto significa que las adif no
corresponden al espacio aéreo soberano y
la de taiwán toma partes de china
continental las autoridades taiwanesas
denuncian la incursión por el suroeste
de los aviones chinos taiwán se
considera un territorio soberano con
gobierno y sistema políticos propios
bajo el nombre de república de china por
el contrario desde china reclaman la
isla y dicen que pueden tomar su control
por la fuerza si es necesario
el lindo pacífico es la región de mayor
tensión entre beijing y washington eeuu
además de ser el principal proveedor
militar de taiwán en las últimas semanas
se comprometió en el pacto august con
australia y reino unido- que busca un
mayor control militar de la zona y en
los últimos días 17 barcos de seis
armadas aliadas de eeuu así como cuatro
portaaviones realizaron maniobras
conjuntas frente a la isla japonesa de
okinawa al noreste de taiwán
antes la fragata británica h ms richmond
tránsito por el estrecho de taiwán
enfureciendo a china